hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fire watch what that was
that that Smokey the Bear spooky spooky
Oh God oh jeez hi friend doing here
watch out for fires don't be swimming
naked with fireworks or I'll come find
you
hey thanks bernzy you're always gonna be
the best of friends with me don't worry
we're always gonna be fast friends
fastest your friends you'll do great
riding in the darkest nights
thanks God Burnie you're so nice to me
I'm nice to everyone okay
alright thanks Bernie I'm gonna take you
with me you're such a delight where did
Bernie go where's Bernie you thought I
was gone did you well I can never leave
we can never leave it speeding
he's not in here is he Oh God
oh no no Bernie no it's not good it's
not good
I can't leave Bernie behind you guys may
be saying I'm irrational right now and
then he's a creepy sign but he's my
friend
how you doing I thought I lost you
oh my god we gotta go Bernie we gotta go
I know fires on the horizon buddy
[Music]
stare into the face of death and know
that all lies in the darkness when fire
consumes all black ash Ernie tell me
what to do
I don't know maybe you should decide for
yourself